super happy to be here
my training is communication so the
kinds of things that i'm interested in
um are really how people use
uh tech online technologies to form and
maintain
uh social relationships i've done some
work looking at
self-presentation strategies and online
dating um the social capital work that
michael talked about
um some work trying to think about
social network sites and how they're
different from
uh previous technologies and
um the the work that i'm sharing today
is a piece that's actually published
already it's in jcmc
um and i'll show you the site later and
so what i
wanted to do was since the
methodological and
and empirical stuff is is already out
there
um i thought what i would do is to kind
of take it a little bit more high level
and maybe do a little bit more
of the kind of intellectual motivation
and thinking
at a higher level than than really just
focusing on the
you know kind of narrow slice of the of
the paper itself
so um when i was going to give this talk
a year ago
um i gave a version of this at mozilla
and and so this was march um you know
of 2020 and i showed this slide and in
my notes
i have um what i was going to say or
what i said back then
which was with this new coronavirus it
seems a little silly to worry about
things like
loneliness and low self-esteem but these
things do matter for quality of life and
have health consequences as well
so um the kind of high level
motivation for this talk is kind of
under better understanding
implications of social media use for
well-being
and at the time i kind of felt the need
to apologize
because you know compared to
something that actually killed us this
kind of like does it make us a little
more lonely
felt a little bit um more trivial but
you know what i i wouldn't say that now
i think if anything
we now are probably more aware of
the kind of importance of connecting
with people
and the ways that online tools do and do
not
support that um so
uh so let's see so the the kind of high
level framing is we have a lot of
um anxiety as a society
right now and and in the past 10 years i
would say about social media
and its implications for well-being our
ability to connect with other people
our ability to even communicate
loneliness
self-esteem and to be honest these
concerns are really nothing new that
when we look historically
at how um how
how new technologies have been treated
um
in popular narratives when first
introduced
um we we see these kind of dystopian
narratives over and over and over again
the telephone um
the the television set even even writing
itself
um which we don't really even think of
as a technology was was
um greeted with a lot of kind of
skepticism when when it was um
first introduced oh i'm thinking about
socrates here
um so when we when we look back
at the scholarship on well-being and
social media use
the the early work really focused on
kind of
how much time are you spending using
this this thing
and over time we've evolved to
really understand that it's much more um
important to look at the kinds of use
and the specific practices that people
are are doing to really understand
um well-being and other outcomes and
one distinction that has emerged as key
in this literature
is active versus passive use you've
probably heard this right are you using
social network sites actively or just
kind of this passive
lurking um and this is true
by the way for how we originally treated
uh research on the internet
um in in general as well that we first
focused on kind of just are you online
or not
and then realize well no it really
matters um a lot more what what you're
actually doing who you're connecting
with what kinds of activities you're
doing
so the two mechanisms in the literature
are social comparison and social
connectedness
and um i'm going to spend a little bit
of time kind of talking about
those um those two to give a sense of
the kind of theoretical motivation for
this work
and this is just kind of a compilation
of studies to show you that this notion
of active versus passive use
is really dominant in the literature and
in fact when we look at a uh 2017
kind of synthesis by uh verdoon
at all he they um
they are looking at kind of you know
whether social network sites enhance or
undermine subjective well-being and you
can see that this um
piece that i've that i've kind of
highlighted talks about these two
um these two routes um one is passive
and one is active and in fact this is
the table
from that paper where you can see up
here there's active use of social
network sites
that enhances social capital and
connectedness and it has a positive
um positive uh relationship with
subjective well-being
and then passive use through this kind
of mechanism
of upward social comparison and envy um
this is a negative sign leading to
uh negatively affecting well-being
subjective well-being and so to kind of
do a little bit of a deep dive on this
social connectedness piece right this is
active
um you know active use and
the the dvs that this literature looks
at are
are multiple but they all you can put
them in the same bucket
things like you know relationship
maintenance social capital social
support
um these are things that we can kind of
measure as an outcome of our social
media or technology use
and when you think about how these
things might come about
this notion that active use is is is
associated with them
isn't surprising right if i um want to
access social capital i need to
to share with my friends that i am in
need of support
and then through clicks they then um
you know offer me this emotional or
informational advice
so this is all basically click based and
one um one special one one stream
of work as michael mentioned has focused
on
social capital implications of facebook
use and as part of that we decided to
kind of look at one slice of activity
and this was broadcasting requests for
um for
help so you may have seen something like
this in your feed you know a request for
information
a recommendation and here we're kind of
focusing on broadcasting
as an affordance of social network sites
right this idea that we can kind of
share to a large audience much like
radio or television right like a mass
media
um outlet but these audiences are people
we know
they know me they can potentially
respond with useful answers you can see
cliff here not all of the answers are as
useful as others
but the point is not only am i accessing
the
informational resources of my network
but these people are all signaling to me
that i'm important to that right that
they took the time to kind of type out a
response
and i'll put in a plug here for kind of
for
socio-technical approaches that that
look at both the social and the
technical um aspects of a particular
phenomena for understanding its its
implications for humans
um so when we look at responding to
friends questions we
see that they're productive empirically
we have some papers on this
um from a social capital perspective and
there's a number of things
going on so we it's creating
expectations of reciprocal behavior
it's helping with this kind of social
grooming function signaling these people
are important to me
there's probably something with the
algorithm going on that we don't really
understand but that it's making people's
you know kind of surfaced
um in terms of the content that they're
sharing
and then from a network perspective um
when i
share a post on a social network site it
goes only to my existing network
when i answer some of michael's question
um for instance
i am now making myself visible to all of
his
network and so this we know from
granovetter and others that these
uh weak ties or friends of friends are
important from an
informational perspective so kind of
sidebar
thinking about tech i mentioned this
broadcasting affordance
um and this is one this this kind of
affordance perspective
is is one that uh many comm scholars are
embracing and and myself as well have
found it very useful and the idea here
is that we're not
trying to describe a particular um
platform at a particular point in time
that that but but
rather that we are kind of kicking our
analysis up a level to think about um
higher level affordances affordances
being kind of
things that these technologies allow us
to do
and in theorizing at this level
we can produce scholarship that
has value even after that technology has
changed or
gone out of business or whatever so
affordances would be things like
um persistence um searchability right
and so
um so here when we're thinking about um
uh when we're thinking about social
network sites and
and sharing questions that we have this
ability to broadcast
much like um earlier media such as the
telephone
but the difference here is that we're
broadcasting to a network of people that
we
have some kind of connection with and um
communication scholars have called this
mass personal so
kind of a combination of mass and
interpersonal
um and in fact when we look at
um this is a copy of the earliest
american newspaper public occurrences
both foreign and domestic
and uh published in 1690
and it's described in the journalism
[Music]
textbooks as a four-page four-page
newspaper but when you
see a picture of it it's only three
pages and this is because the last
page was left blank for people to add
their own news or opinions on and leave
it at the tavern for the next
person so so this notion that kind of
broadcast you know it maths and
interpersonal
affordances are are connected
um this isn't necessarily new but this
is something we think of
with social media and of course when we
think about
the affordances of a newspaper like this
versus
a facebook post in terms of a bit
interactivity synchronicity
search searchability persistence right
we cannot these are all attributes that
we can associate with social media
and and which really kind of shape those
interactions in
important ways so the second
kind of mechanism that was in that
verdun um
chart is social comparison and the idea
here so i talked about clicking being
associated with these kind of beneficial
social connectedness um now we're going
to focus on the kind of downside right
which
is um social comparison and
this is associated with viewing right so
viewing social media friends contents
content the literature suggests sorry
about my cat
um leads to negative social comparison
and
social self-esteem effects and the idea
here
is that i am comparing myself to my
um peers and they are
posting only the great things that are
happening to them
and if i don't have this awareness i
will negatively um
upwards compare myself to them and feel
badly about myself
or feel envious about myself and then
there's other
kind of components about this as well so
the like paradox
um they're getting more likes than me
empirically we
we know this um and uh
and that these are peers they're not you
know kind of celebrities right they're
more salient comparison
comparisons so point being is that
these two kind of streams have been
treated as independent
um in the literature for the most part
and
one of the things that we wanted to kind
of play with um
in this project was to really
move away from this kind of active
versus passive
dichotomy and to instead consider that
um
interacting and viewing might be more
productively conceived on
on a spectrum um of high and low
on both as opposed to you know just
passive and and just active and when we
do that
um we have this kind of quadrant of four
kinds of users right
we have these four uh four kinds of
users
um and uh with the idea that you can be
high on one or low on the other
low on both or high on the other and
when we think about the
what the literature then would propose
right with this and i'm i'm
oversimplifying a bit
um but with social connectedness you are
you know you
you have to interact right so you're
kind of high
on on interacting regardless of whether
you're actually
viewing or not okay and
um when we um think about
so so the idea here is that we're we're
clicking but we're not
we don't necessarily know whether people
are kind of authentically engaged
and i'll talk a little bit here just
about eye contact or eye gaze right
which in face-to-face communication is
how we communicate how we show attention
right how we show that we're listening
um and we give out a lot of information
um that we're not even aware that we're
processing as individuals through
our um through our gaze and this may be
one you know reason why some of us feel
fatigued um online because we can't
though those same cues about uh where
people are looking
are are less are less evident
and when we think about how this
translates in an online environment
um you can't really tell whether someone
is looking at or has been
shown something unless you leave a
visible trace right unless you
as a user click comment share right that
these are all kind of
signals that then um are
are the only way that we can kind of
communicate that we've
seen or are kind of paying attention to
content
and of course this is how systems you
decide what to
what ads to show us um and we can think
about different
kinds of clicks and how they what is
their value for
social relationships the happy birthday
post is kind of the canonical signal
um or canonical example of social
grooming
um social grooming right in primates
being away
you know literally picking nits off one
another as a way to signal to build
trust to kind of
you know signal um signal liking
um nurturing one another reciprocity
and we can kind of think of happy
birthday messages
as a as some kind of modern-day
equivalent of
of that kind of um social grouping and
then thinking about social comparison
this is you know where you you have to
kind of view
right to look uh to feel this comparison
but again the literature it doesn't
really speak to the extent to which
interacting might
um might affect that and here
we can see that platforms have kind of
played with
hiding likes as a way because likes are
such a salient
you know when you quantify something it
becomes much more easy to kind of
compare
so um number of likes being
uh implicated in these kind of negative
self-esteem
um dynamics and
um as i said most of the literature um
talks about upwards comparison and
social media as having these negative
implications
there is this piece that i'll point out
by adrian meyer and colleagues
um that's looking at what are the
conditions under which
um viewing uh images
that uh actually results in kind of
inspiration right
positive and i will um allow you to
guess which of these two in this is from
their
stimuli um from their experiment and
i'll allow you to guess which of these
two
is um pictures of leaves is more um
inspirational
um but at any rate uh so so here we have
this
again this kind of quadrant of you know
interacting and viewing
and so what does that mean for someone
who is then high
on viewing and clicking right so the
predictions from literature could go
either way either they're benefiting
from their poster
from their their posting or they're kind
of taking a hit to their self-esteem
from viewing right and and one of the
things that i want to suggest is that
these two things may
interact in ways that that treating them
independently doesn't allow us to see so
for instance
maybe when you um see someone posting
about something terrible that hap
said something great that happened to
them and you
um feel obligated to write a comment
maybe that gets you out of your own
you know head that that do benefiting um
other people is good for us right um
that this is more
less self-focused that maybe some things
are happening that we don't
quite um you know can't quite predict
maybe
this is a very simple way of suggesting
that maybe in some ways they're kind of
canceling each other out
and when we look at recent meta analyses
indeed we do find that the kind of
uh fear narratives about social media
use are
not necessarily supported here's a
recent piece that finds that
um you know this association between
digital technology
and adolescent well-being is uh explains
four percent of the variation in
well-being
um so another uh kind of user
theoretical user type we consider is is
what we call the
indiscriminate clicker right and from a
social capital perspective
this person probably benefits in the
short term right they're they're
clicking they're they're
signaling attention to a lot of people
but you know they're not really paying
attention
um this is kind of the interpersonal
equivalent of
a of a click farm employee right and
going back to
our happy birthday um example
right we can think about the kind of the
click
the happy birthday post as a form of
currency
signaling attention investment in a
relationship
okay back in the olden days
um back on you know uh you had to kind
of
navigate to a person's page and type out
um a message and so from thinking about
like donna's
work on um on signaling theory
right this is a pretty um a pretty
uh honest signal of attention when you
when you're when you're typing something
out
um then facebook kind of aggregated
these all on one page and it became a
slightly
less honest or cheaper signal of of
actual
attention and now we have tools like
birthday buddy that tells us birthdays
are important make them
special um yet so special that the
extension automatically posts a
personalized birthday wish on your
facebook friend's wall so you don't even
have to do anything right so
if all of your thousands of social media
contacts used
um an application like this to say happy
birthday
that that essentially becomes no signal
at all right
all right and finally i'm sorry i know
i'm going kind of fast but i do want to
leave some time
for um discussion at the end so
hopefully you can keep up with me um so
this this last quadrant these are people
who
are um viewing right they're
they're high on viewing they spend a lot
of time looking at content but they
don't click
right they don't comment they don't
click they don't leave a trace
and we might expect that this would um
from the literature we would predict
that this would have poor well-being
outcomes right because they're not
doing the things that we know benefit us
um but our
you know kind of speculation points to
one scenario
where where this might actually be more
um powerful in terms of social
connectedness
and the example i'll share with you is
um
this post of my dog coco when she was a
puppy
and i um had people who didn't um
didn't post didn't like didn't leave any
trace
yet the next day in the office back when
that was a thing
um you know came up to me and said oh i
saw you got a puppy
she's so cute you know what are you
gonna name her um and so
from a social capital kind of social
relational investment perspective
this was actually a much stronger signal
because they
they saw it they remembered it right
they brought it up
and we had a whole interaction um around
it
so even though from a kind of you know
trace
data perspective this interaction
didn't exist right even facebook doesn't
know when people
come up to you in the hall and talk to
you about something um
it still is very kind of powerful from a
if we're thinking about interpersonal
relationships
okay so now to the empirical piece um
this paper as i said is
is published in the journal of computer
uh computer media
communication um and it is co-authored
with um penny trio
robin brewer arthy israni and sarita
shonabek all faculty or
students at the school of information at
u of m
penny is now at google she graduated
last year
so the research questions um that are
kind of powering the study um so
one is that we were interested in
understanding what was the relationship
between
viewing and clicking right and the way
that we kind of operationalize this was
to
um use eye tracking to
show people their facebook feed
and to calculate how long they looked at
particular content and
to um also then capture whether they
clicked on it or not
right so we might predict that people
are spending a lot of time looking at
stuff they click at and and kind of
you know not no time at things that they
weren't um
that they didn't click on and that's not
what we found
um and then we also uh combined this eye
tracking data with
interview data um where we really wanted
to understand in users
own kind of words and how they
understood what a click was right so
what kind of guided their decisions
to click or not click on on content in
facebook was our kind of research um
research focus and we
invited university of michigan staff to
come into the lab
we had a gender balance and and
tried to recruit a diverse sample um you
can see age-wise we
we were okay with that um these were you
know sports coaches
administrative assistants um custodians
um so
pretty pretty um you know lots of
different kinds of people
not not undergrads and they came into
the lab
where they we had an eye tracking device
set up on the desktop computer
we calibrated them we had them browse
their
um an exciting university web page for
two minutes to get used to the
environment and then we asked them to
engage in
a seven minute facebook session where we
asked them and we so the instructions
were to look at your facebook news feed
and interact with it as you normally
would including any liking or commenting
um
and you know unlike other studies where
participants were instructed to be
either you know active or passive we
really wanted to kind of understand
their natural behaviors so we just
told them to do what you would normally
do and then we recorded
the content of their feed and where
their eye gaze landed
and also whether they clicked or not um
and so this is an example of the eye
clicking data and you can see that
essentially
it's it's um these dots are where the
gaze
um the gaze was and when
um the the bigger the dot the longer the
gaze this is
someone who is not gazing very long in
any one particular thing
okay um so we didn't we didn't code the
entire seven minutes we
uh divided it into um three bins
and then um sampled from each of those
so we had um
21 posts per participant
and then sorry we also did a
interview where we asked them some
questions about
um recall and also about their you know
experience
referring to the logs um during that
time
and then had them do us uh fill out a
survey
okay so the first question was
uh what was the relationship between
viewing um so duration of eye gaze
associated
with each piece of content in their feed
and and
clicking okay and clicking was anything
that left a visible trace for other
users
okay so scrolling or clicking through a
photo album wasn't counted as a click
but liking a photo
uh would be and when we compared clicked
posts
with unclicked posts in a linear mix
model to account for the nested nature
of the data
right because we had multiple data
points for each participant
we found that there was actually no
significant difference
in time spent gazing on content that
they
clicked on or didn't click on they did
spend more time looking
at comment content that they later
commented on
um and i just want to point out that we
stopped counting when they started
typing so it's not just this isn't just
an artifact that it takes longer to
to type okay so um so so this is kind of
the
um big quant piece that that there was
that the people are not um that they're
spending the same time
looking at clicked and unclicked content
um and then we
uh turn now to the interview data and
um wondering um you know how people kind
of understand their own clicking and
viewing practices
and then kind of focusing in on this
idea of the non-click
like the non-click as a thing um
as a thing that you purposefully do
right
and so we um in in a kind of thematic
analysis we found that there were three
audience related concerns associated
with non-clicks
so do i want the person to see this
click the poster
do i want our networks to see the click
and then the third
kind of audience was the platform itself
do i want the platform to see this click
so and i'll start out by just saying of
course
you know it's not the case that we are
expecting people to click on every
single piece of content
and people do of course say that you
know
sometimes it's really not necessary
right unless it's
you know this amazing cat video i'm not
going to click on every cat video i see
um so what what we're interested in is
instances where people
did attend to it they did think it was
you know
interesting or worthy in some way but
they decided not to click
right that that was a deliberate
decision
and so the first audience i talked about
was the the recipient right so this is
the poster
the person who who posted that piece of
content
and um they didn't you know so one one
reason that our participants talked
about was that they didn't want to
seem to endorse certain times of certain
kinds of
posts or behavior right so one person
talked about
you know if if someone is is their their
kid won the softball game
and they're just only talking about how
great their kid was and not the team
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna click on
that right
um or another related instance was that
these non-clickers didn't want to be
accountable or call attention to their
activities
um so here we have one quote who says um
one one participant who says you know as
a male
person i might notice pictures but i try
not to give the impression that i'm
noticing pictures right because
sometimes it would be inappropriate me
for me to click like on their
bathing suit picture um i'm going to
scroll past it even if i noticed it
because they might be looking for that
attention but not from me
um or another person who talked about
kind of um going deep into people's
feeds because she was kind of curious
about them
and she talked about how that wasn't
socially acceptable right that that was
kind of creepy to like
someone's picture from three years ago
that you you know just met
um and then um the the second kind of
bucket
of audience motivations um
driving non-click decisions was about
the network right and so this would be
the
you know the either my friend network um
your
you know the posters friend network or
or the kind of
you know community at large so here this
is
you know i think we can kind of think of
this as privacy concerns
um to some extent that i don't want
everyone seeing my comments
um here's one person who just says i
don't click anything
and even talks about how someone said
hey why don't you
like my stuff and i said i don't like
stuff and they said yeah but you like
other people's stuff
so they've been watching and tracking
and so at this point the person said i'm
just gonna
stay away from any clicking um because i
i don't
you know i don't i don't want to have to
justify why i like
something and didn't like it something
else and then the third
um kind of big audience bucket is the
platform
itself so this is where people talked
about the algorithm
right about the about not wanting about
being conscious of the algorithm um
seeing what they click on and and kind
of feeding them more of that
right so here's someone who's talking
about how they second guess
themselves on a clicking on a diabetes
site because they didn't want to get
more ads
um here's another person talking about
baby pictures and why she says i can't
click
i can't like any more of those pictures
i want that baby out of my feed
i've seen that baby so much and i've
never seen them in real life
so again it's people you know being
aware of this notion that clicking leads
uh that clicking trains the algorithm
and and you'll get more of that stuff
and wanting to
to be invisible from that perspective
and then i brought up the i showed you
the picture of coco and talked about how
people had you know mentioned her to to
me the other day and we had this
in our data as well so here we have a
woman saying that she went to
peru with her daughter and posted some
vacation pictures
and that she noticed that people use
that as what she calls a
conversation starter and then she liked
this right she says if you're actually
noticing that i posted this picture
and you can bring it up later on and
talk with me about it
clearly there's some level of interest
there's a greater connection there
it's so easy to like something on
facebook it's just you know you're just
doing it to be polite
i would rather you mention it to me in
real life you actually want real people
to interact with you
how many likes something gets is not
super important um so here
again from a kind of relational
investment social grooming
you know social signaling perspective
this is
more um more valuable
as a as a signal of attention and yet
invisible from a kind of trace data
um you know method perspective
and i'll talk about that as one of what
i think the
contributions of this piece are first i
want to talk about two
theoretical implications and then i'll
finish with a
design design implication so
um so i'll just kind of uh go through
these so i think the first
um is maybe as a nudge
to researchers to kind of rethink this
simple you know passive versus active
paradigm that this was one of the
kind of um trends in the literature that
we were responding to
um and our findings suggest that social
media scholarship
could should consider other approaches
to get categorizing
user activity above and beyond this kind
of
dichotomous and limiting active versus
passive distinction
so we see that there was no significant
difference in viewing time
between clicked and non-click content
and
our interview data also talk about the
fact that you know people were really
kind of um had this notion of the
non-click as an intentional
act that resulted from conscious and
thoughtful engagement
even you know with content that they
that they paid attention to
um and uh so we
also kind of think about the
interpersonal aspects of this and
and well-being perspective and when i
say cross-channel interactions
i mean you see content in a social
network site and then you pick up the
phone
or you mention it to the person the next
day in the hall or you send a text
and that those are actually stronger
signals of of relational investment
than uh than clicks so
thinking about this kind of i talked a
little bit about
you know this kind of being a passive
framing right that this person
doing this picking up the phone instead
of clicking would be coded
as passive right by any social media
researcher
uh depending who was depending
solely on the trace data set
but now we also want to suggest that
maybe active uses of facebook also
would benefit from some more theoretical
refinement
given how people are actually using
these sites and the
um platform affordances so for instance
posting
is usually operationalized as direct
communication but you know when we think
about it
um you know maybe that post is hidden by
the algorithm who knows
maybe the post um is ignored
and in fact that would actually lead to
well-being declines right you feel
badly if you ask a question and no one
answers it
um maybe we want to focus more on what
that content is right not just that it's
a click or not
and with the kind of request for help is
being one example of that
and then often commenting and posting
are kind of
put into the same bucket but they're
really very different um
from many perspectives i mentioned the
network aspect is one right that
there's a difference between posting to
your own um group of friends versus
posting um commenting on a friends where
you're
then being visible to their um to their
network
we spend a little bit of time talking
about the interpersonal implications of
this
non-click and channel switching and you
know
essentially um that that our
participants
um you know kind of sometimes engaged in
this gratuitous
um liking and commenting and
you know that when we think about how
these click infrastructures have evolved
historically
where we're really removing friction
right we're making it so easy for people
to click
that at a certain point maybe that click
becomes
um useless from a kind of interpersonal
perspective so
one suggestion we make is maybe platform
designers
might want to introduce friction back
into
these relational investment gestures on
social media to increase the strength of
the signal so for instance i had a
birthday last week
and i really noticed when people instead
of just saying you know
hbd they took the time to find a photo
of the two of us
from the past and and po and share that
instead
um and so that was you know less
friction but more um
more meaningful and um this
is i'm gonna skip this because i wanna
have time for
um questions at the end so um
yeah and again just here we're kind of
talking about um
how these how we signal authentic
attention and that it's not just based
on um
you know on on clicks so
this kind of leads to the methodological
implications of the non-click right and
i
you know i'm in a school of information
i work with a lot of computer scientists
i understand the excitement about
click data and you know the idea that it
represents this kind of gold standard of
behavioral data
um when we compare it to self-report
um but i do
point out that you know if we're relying
on click data alone
we may be missing really critical um
aspects of what we really
should more productively conceive of as
kind of an ecosystem
of different platforms and different
communication channels
and um one way that
we can kind of um you know so then of
course the question becomes well how do
we study the non-click if it doesn't
exist um and one thing that um
one one approach is to do kind of you
know multi-channel studies where you are
not just focusing on facebook only but
rather
um also asking about you know text
messages or face-to-face
interactions or picking up the phone or
you know snapchat or instagram or email
and kind of
really thinking about this as a
as you know the notion that oftentimes
these pieces
you know interactions can start in one
platform and
move to other platforms and if you're
only
asking about you know twitter or
facebook or snapchat or whatever it is
you're really missing out on that and i
say this
as someone who has done dozens of these
studies
um but i'm trying not to um
and then of course multi-method i think
you know focusing
um under acknowledging that server level
data
may not give you the entire um
you know the entire um story but that
it's important to kind of
as we did here you know look at other
talk to people for instance about how
they understand their
own use and maybe there's other
techniques as well i know for instance
um you know there was uh you can ask
people what they regret posting or
using server level data to explore posts
that were typed out but not posted
so there are some other techniques and
then finally
i'm thinking about design implications
right so
and this is a little bit more kind of
high level i'm not just talking about
the design of one platform but kind of
how we as a society um think about
what we what we pay attention to and so
here's a picture of a desire path
and the idea is that these footsteps
right through the
grassy area show where pathway should be
built because this is where people
actually walked and i think the same
idea is used often when we're when when
platforms are deciding kind of what
content to surface right so
if other people have clicked on it um
you know let's show it to more
to more people right in in the same way
and of course this is we know this is
how they work right facebook
tells you if you want to know why you're
seeing something it's because
you've clicked on other things or other
people have clicked on things and they
think it'll be important to you
um but really what i want to ask here is
kind of what are the logic
what are the consequences of this logic
right that assumes that clicks
represent attention or value right like
what what are the
what are the what what happens when we
move this
metaphor um online and
the story that i that kind of prompted
some of this work
um so this is a facebook group that i'm
in this is from a couple years ago
i'm sharing this with permission i took
out the person's name
um and really what happened was a
group of this is a group of academic um
mothers
and a woman posted a a story
about um how uh
and the article was written by a woman
of color
about how she felt invisible in society
and
the post got very little
interaction um and then essentially kind
of disappeared
okay and then at the same time
another another uh post was shared
that got a lot of attention and it was
something very
silly it was a picture of a spider okay
and then the next day
um this this woman wrote to the group
and said i've been thinking about and
and and i should say that
then people kind of started noticing hey
what why did
why did no one comment on this picture
about this woman of color feeling
invisible what what happened there
and so this is the reflection that she
that
one of the members shared the next day
and she says i've been thinking about
this recent case where a post with an
article about
black women being invisible was itself
apparently invisible
i think that one thing that might be
contributing to the problem is that it's
kind of difficult to know
whether or how to respond to posts about
oppressed groups as a member of the
oppressing group
i take it as one thing that what we
should not do is respond with our own
personal take on the story our excuses
how shocked we are my strategy was to
read and learn and be quiet
but now i am worried that this isn't
helpful because the facebook algorithm
reacts to reactions so this diminishes
visibility
and because this is indistinguishable to
the poster from ignoring
um and so then she goes on to say you
know what what
what's the best thing to do on facebook
to kind of signal boost or show that
you're listening
without taking up space right i don't
liking
is not appropriate um let's talk about
this as a
as a as a group and kind of and figure
it out
um and so the question then that we ask
is you know what how is how do we want
to
account or or allow people to express
this notion that this is important
content
i want other people to see it i i
thought about it
i'm i'm not taking up space in this
conversation
um but it's it's important but i don't
want to click on it
and and to then um you know
not have that post basically kind of
disappear when the platform says oh hey
no one's
clicking on this it must not be
important and so
we suggest here at the end sorry for the
wall of text but we suggest at the end
that you know stories about kind of
complex and difficult social phenomena
may fade out of social media feeds
because people don't have you know the
time to post a comment or maybe they
don't know what to say
they don't want to just post a
potentially inappropriate reaction
and and that you know non-clicks on this
more kind of complex
content may inadvertently trade these
algorithms to highlight content
that's easy to respond to right like the
spider poster you could just hit
honey funny haha and move on um
and so here well i'll just end with this
point that that more
scholarly attention should be paid to
the social and political implications of
these algorithmic logics that assume
clicking alone can identify worthy
content
and we also kind of articulate this this
call for action that platforms should
really think about
how do you design for listening right
how
how can you as a user say this is
important
but i don't want to become a speaker in
this conversation
it's not my place i want to listen i
want to learn from it
it's important but i none of these
options are um
are are appropriate and i i will say
that these data were collected
um before the facebook care um
reaction was introduced and i do think
that that
does some of this um does some of this
work so
i will um end with that here's kind of
some
um high level points and
a link to the paper which i know you
can't click on um but you can search for
non-click
lsn jcmc i can also put it in chat and
i am going to i guess stop sharing my
screen so that i can
see people and um thank you very much
i'll kick one off while while folks uh
are prepping
um first of all i really love the idea
of thinking about other signaling
mechanisms
uh that's i think a thing that we've
really not
gotten very deep in in the design of
these systems and i
i really think there's something there
my question
is around you coming coming back to your
initial
um observation which is totally right
that
you we have things like thai strength
and well-being
being as a result in many ways like of
of costly communication right the social
grooming analysis the honest signals all
this is sort of saying that when i put
effort and time into something
that's what makes you it makes clear
that that i value you because i've as
i've done it
and i and when you split out your 2x2
there was still some implication that
yes there might be other values but at
the same time the non-click is still
not perceived as costly right
so if i'm not doing anything that you
can see
if you're the poster it's it's it's not
a costly communication
um and with the exception of the one
case that you pointed out where someone
brings it offline
but that's all probably already between
a strong tie right because we're meeting
up
in person so i'm just wondering
is there is there a hope he steers still
here for non-clicks leading to
good well-being results or do you feel
that you've
you know does do we wind up in the same
position at the end of the day
that essentially what was called being
called low activity
here i'm just focusing on on non-clicks
is it still just
winding up with ultimately i'm i'm not
engaging in costly communication so
we're not building thai strength i'm not
i'm not engaging in the well-being
behaviors that that help in the long
term
yeah i mean i think um i i think you're
you're assuming that this kind of
cross-channel
communication happens primarily or maybe
only with strong ties
and i would say that's not what our data
suggested and
um so the kind of meeting someone in the
hallway
um you know back got knock on wood that
that'll be a thing at some point i mean
those aren't necessarily
strong ties but you might be um you know
facebook friends with with colleagues
from
from work that would be one example the
other um
instance that people talked about in the
data that i recall
is um when they wanted a kind of
more more of a interaction
and so with like say an old high school
friend for instance this would be
something where
maybe they wouldn't text the person
because i i think that does imply you
have their phone number right but
um like facebook moving from
um a facebook post and comment to
a messenger um interaction so
so i think there probably is a little
bit more wiggle room in terms of tie
strength and who
people are um doing this kind of
platform hopping around but
but i do think that you're um
you know i but i but i like the kind of
motivation of thinking about
how in the how how can the non-click
um what are other ways that
we can um signal attention
if we don't want the you know if we
don't want to say tell
facebook if we don't want to click for
other reasons
um other than that kind of bringing it
into
another um another channel i mean
there's also kind of interesting work
that i know um hancock has done like
with this idea that when you
um see content and then you kind of
seamlessly blend it into conversations
as a way of kind of
ingratiating yourself with the person so
he did that study right where they
um looked up at someone's profile about
what their favorite
hamburger was or is banned or whatever
and then
in an interaction where they were told
to make that person like you
they were kind you know they were able
to kind of um
blend those into the conversation so i
could see that as another way of
you know this information being used
that's
not associated with just like a cheap
like
well um i really appreciated this work
it's gone into
a lot more depth than i've heard about
um on this before especially that
you know the passive stuff is not
necessarily negative
um really really interesting i wonder if
you've also done some work
on secondary effects like um if there's
a negative feedback loop
that if you see that there's already
been so many likes you sort of think
that's enough and don't like it yourself
or if you see
there haven't been any um for you know
this person's cat or their workout or
whatever that
you're more likely to do it or if you
see that there's been a whole lot of
comments about
you know that's a really cute blue um
and there's really nothing more to say
about it you might not say something
where
whereas um uh yeah so
what people have already done affect
what people do
um in reaction in the future
yeah so i think that's probably i i mean
so
i think that's a great question the work
we've done um focus it that that speaks
to that i think most directly is the
question asking and i where we saw
um depending on the kind of question
there were differences
in kind of the number of responses um so
for instance if it's a straight
informational factual question you only
need
one answer right you need the right
factual answer
and then you wouldn't expect to see 20
other people repeating the same thing
for something like uh recommendations or
advice
right where a diversity of perspectives
is is really what you want that's where
we would see
more responses coming in so so i guess i
i think you're totally like i i think
the
intuition is right and i would say that
the only way that we've kind of
empirically
studied that particular question is
through the the
the differences in the kinds that we did
a study where we kind of coded the
different kinds of questions
and the responses and had people
rate how useful the responses were
and i think that's where um different
kinds of questions
kind of you know demand different um
kinds of answers or different numbers of
answers
so so i'll bring up a couple questions
from
uh folks who joined one is um i'll
paraphrase it asking around
how how these same questions are gonna
get transformed in
in live or sort of synchronous
interactions things like
clubhouse where it's happening you know
at the same time rather than
in this asynchronous manner is there
going to be a similar notion of
of how how these sort of click or
non-click interactions might play out
you know how are the mechanisms here
gonna gonna unroll
yeah that's i mean so um
so i think the difference right with um
i'm thinking of clubhouse and
synchronous
audio is that um only
one person can speak at a time
so there is um you know so this idea
that
that 50 people could comment or like
without affecting the other people's
ability to
comment or like right is is pretty is
pretty different so i think
um and i don't i guess i don't i think
part of it would kind of depend on the
um platform itself and how it's
you know allowing people to to signal
attention or not but um and i don't know
what i'm trying to remember with
clubhouse i've only played with it a bit
but i don't know that there's
ways of of of of kind of
um you know um
clicking in this endorsing in the same
way that you could with
um facebook so i think the important
piece there would be
looking at the affordance of
synchronicity
and how with asynchronous communication
um you don't have those um
limits or constraints on
on on who can participate in the same
way you do
um with a with a forum like this right
only one person
can can talk at a time
excellent and one final one noting that
we're just about at time he's referring
to
um to the emotional contagion study
looking at how
essentially posts can have um
you know small scale effects on our on
our emotional states
and his question is focused on
when something will have sort of like a
positive contagion sort of inspiration
rather than creating jealousy as as he
puts it so
you gave this example sort of like you
know nice photos of leaves versus bad
photos of leaves or photos of a vacation
making me
feel relaxed rather than jealous and i
think they're
underlying his question seems to be sort
of like well what
are there ways to differentiate these
uses and there are
are there are also different kinds of
signals that get used in each case
yeah so that so i mean i think there's
probably two things that we would look
at
one would be the the kind of content
itself so in that case it was the
the imagery and how kind of evocative
um and you know visually appealing
the the the thing that people were
responding to but then i think
it's probably also useful to
look at the comment stream and the
interactions there
and that that would really um
you know that i could see that also
affecting
how you as a viewer um your
your emotional response to a post and
a set of um responses and and this i
think is probably and
and then also i think you know yourself
as an
as an audience to yourself and the fact
that you
you know type it you don't want to be an
ass and say something
mean so you type in something supportive
and in doing that then
how does you know how does that affect
your um
own kind of emotional you know um state
at that
at that moment so um so yeah
this is probably not a good answer i
think it's a great question i'm hopeful
i'm hopeful that we'll see
more work that kind of is able to parse
out
those kinds of details um and and i
think the interaction
is is critical to look at and also very
hard to
um manipulate in an experiment only yes
excellent why don't we call it here
thank you so much for joining us